if you think shit's teched out now you
haven't seen nothing this just
keeps moving in every generation does
the same thing they take the thing
that's in place for granted without
realizing how much disruption's coming
as we get comfortable with facial
recognition at the airport because we
love not standing in line now that's how
you're going to be walking into stadium
and how the screens in the stadium are
going to be paying attention to you
shit's gonna get weird the robots are
gonna win
but we've got a little while metaverse
and Horizon might be far now but do you
really think it's impossible that
seven-year-olds today at 25 are living
in that Universe of course it's possible
we live in it now it's called us being
in this for four hours a day